all right let me go through this door
Everything Changes you slip up
you're dead we'll never see the waking
world again
okay
what are we waiting for
that's the spirit
all right welcome to my world kid brand
new dream still under construction
[Music]
look good
I'm a flipping Outlaw so I don't play by
the rules but here's the rules rule
number one keep a low profile you don't
want to get caught messing around in
other people's dreams trust me if the
dream pigs catch you they will
my bad buddy if the dream cops catch you
they will lock you up and throw away the
key doomeda rot in a dingy girl present
cell for all of eternity till he cease
to exist entirely
so blend in yeah because you totally
Blended rule number two stay focused
we're not here to have fun okay we get
in we find the next door and we get out
on to the next dream our one and only
mission is finding those pearls rule
number three we're not friends we're not
Partners I am the boss El Jefe okay you
do as I said you got it so rule number
three is just a bunch of aggressive
statements
nobody likes a smart dog kid
[Music]